Thank you to today's sponsor lingo to an online language school,
where you can learn or boost your skills in a number of different languages,
including German,
improve your fluency in just three months and get a 100% refund on your lessons.
Click the link in the description. Hello, set of rules.
Welcome to the line and focus channel. And my name is Paul. Today.
We're going to compare standard German and Bavarian a German dialect.
That's so different from standard German that most other German speakers find it
difficult to understand.
Bavarian is spoken in the state of Bavaria in Southeastern Germany,
as well as in most of Austria and South tea role it's elite because it includes
most speakers in Austria. You may hear it referred to as Ostrow Bavarian,
it's a group of upper German dialect or all by Deutsche while standard German
is based largely on central German dialects.
There are differences in all aspects of the language, including pronunciation,
vocabulary, and grammar, but of course,
Bavarian speakers can also speak standard German,
but with their own characteristic,
Bavarian accent Bavarian is spoken along a sliding scale with standard German
and its speakers mix it with varying degrees of standard German,
depending on the situation and social context. For example,
they may speak full on Bavarian with their family and close friends,
standard German with some dialectal elements with acquaintances and standard
German at a business meeting.
This sliding scale between Bavarian and standard German is sometimes compared to
the one between Scotts and standard English in Scotland.
It's also worth noting that in large cities like Munich,
there are many people who move there from other parts of Germany and from around
the world.
So the speech there is normally closer to standard German Bavarian can be
further broken down into three groups,
Northern Bavarian central Bavarian and Southern Bavarian.
It has no standard form or standardized spelling. And across these three groups,
there are numerous local varieties that somewhat differ from each other.
So in order to compare with standard German,
we'll focus on one particular variety.
The dialect [inaudible] spoken in upper Bavaria,
near Munich because Bavarian differs from one area to another and people mix it
with standard German to varying degrees. Some people may say, Hey,
I don't say it that way. Or, Hey,
I say it both ways that's to be expected because people use nonstandard dialects
in different ways,
but hopefully these examples will give you a general idea of how Bavarian
differs from standard German pronunciation are,
is often trilled in Bavarian.
Whereas it's normally a uvular fricative in German, for example,
a word for rain in standard German and in Bavarian
also notice what happens to the G sound,
the evil after the G is reduced or basically dropped and G becomes
nasalized since it comes before. And so it's pronounced no,
but the biggest difference in Bavarian is it's vowels. For example, ah,
becomes Oh, in standard German,
meaning roof becomes dolls.
Meaning water becomes.
Especially distinctive.
Is Bavarians diphthongs.
It has different diphthongs from standard German and more diphthongs than
standard German.
I in standard German often corresponds to UWA in Bavarian
meaning journey becomes.
Highest.
Meaning hot becomes who S Ooh or
often corresponds to UWA the word for good in standard German
and in Bavarian. And the word for must.
MUAs E.
Spelled with E often corresponds to ER,
ni meaning never becomes
meaning gets becomes correct.
I'll often corresponds to oil height, meaning stop becomes
meaning so or thus becomes
meaning once becomes.
Ill.
Often corresponds to oui, meaning example becomes
spirit, meaning played, becomes exploited,
and there are other sound changes that result in we as well, like Shula,
which means school becomes Sui.
Other sound changes.
Unstressed eat tends to be highly reduced or dropped meaning
to forget becomes Ferguson,
Ben or boon at the end of words, tends to become, mm, with an M.
The word for screws becomes
then or an N at the end of words, corresponds with not in Bavarian,
there's this word meaning to mean or to think mine. And when I,
and notice that once again, we see the correspondence of the sounds I, and UWA,
you've probably noticed that Bavarian is normally spelled to reflect how it's
pronounced though its spelling isn't standardized. For example, ER,
and standard German is often pronounced as a vowel without an R sound,
not only in Bavarian, but colloquial standard German as well in Bavarian,
it's normally spelled with an a for example,
meaning master and Westa. And one more example,
I've been meaning to connect and
vocabulary. Some very basic words are different in Bavarian.
Even if they come from the same root as the standard German words,
they often have different forms.
You may have noticed at the beginning of the video,
that the words for hello are different. Hello.
Say the word for I E.
Indefinite article in its masculine nominative singular form.
Ah, the word for you in the singular dish.
Let's look at a sentence. When you see and hear the sentences in this section,
you'll probably notice a lot of little changes.
Like the ones we looked at in the previous section on pronunciation,
these sentences mean I have a present for you in standard German
[inaudible] and in Bavarian.
[Inaudible].
Here. Notice the difference in the subject pronoun we just saw and notice the
different vowels in the verbs,
meaning have the indefinite article is different as we saw above.
And the word for present loses its short evil in Bavarian,
or at least it's really reduced the preposition meaning for it takes a different
form and the personal pronoun, meaning you takes a different form.
As we saw above the word for me in the date of case,
ma the word for is,
is the word for also, ah,
and now a pair of sentences,
meaning he told me it's his birthday today too in standard German
[inaudible] and in Bavarian.
Yeah. So [inaudible] does height. I, you put stock is.
Here. We see the different form of the first person,
singular data of personal pronoun. In other words, me in the date of case here,
we see the different word for also,
and here we see the difference in the third person, singular form of the verb,
meaning to be meaning is in English and looking at the other words,
you'll notice some differences in pronunciation and word form that we looked at
earlier.
It seems that the speaker of the Bavarian sentence actually said this in the
present tense, not the past tense as some of you may have noticed,
but that's okay because we're focusing on vocabulary at the moment.
Sometimes not just different forms, but completely different words are used.
These sentences mean it's hot today. Isn't it in standard German
and in Bavarian.
Is who has hired Natewa.
Here. We see a Bavarian version of the phrase,
but an alternate word can be used instead gal or gay depending on the
area. It simply means isn't it? Yes.
The weather is strange this year in standard German.
And in Bavaria.
Yo, this Veda is higher set. Some.
Notice that the standard German phrase, meaning this year is Jesus. Yeah.
While Bavarian has a different word higher,
this word cite Psalm could also be selled some here.
We see that in Bavarian, the S is voiceless.
It's not pronounced Z as in standard German
in standard German. The words for up or upward are meaning up there,
away from your current position and meaning up here towards your
current position in Bavarian, the preferred words are.
I'll see, and I'll fit alpha.
There are also cases in which both words are used in standard German. And,
but there's a preference or tendency to use one word more than the other.
For example, in Bavarian,
there's a tendency to use the word meaning talk more than
meaning speak. Another example of that is the word for throw in standard German.
The more common way is while in Bavarian it's
grammar standard German has for grammatical cases,
nominative accusative, genitive and dative.
Bavarian has no genitive case. Possession is shown in different ways.
For example, take the phrase,
meaning the man's house in standard German house here,
we see that the noun phrases in the genitive form,
this definite article is in the masculine singular genitive form.
And the noun has the masculine genitive singular case ending in Bavarian.
One way to say this is using fun, which means.
This house for more.
[Inaudible] is a contraction of fun and dam the masculine singular data of
definite article.
So this is like saying the house of the man another way is to simply use the
date.
Of case did more say house.
The definite article and the noun are in the date of here.
And then it's followed by the possessive pronoun sign.
This is like saying to the man his house.
Another difference involved as a verb tenses in Bavarian,
the past tense is not used. The perfect tense is used. Instead.
These sentences mean I laughed in standard German and in
Bavarian, he lost literally I have laughed.
There are two exceptions that verb sine meaning to be,
and the verb Volin meaning want another difference is that in
Bavarian, there are double negatives,
which don't really occur in standard German.
At least not double negatives like this, which result in a negative meaning.
Here's the sentence. Meaning I have never heard that before in standard German
word for word it's that have I yet never heard in Bavaria?
[Inaudible] word for it.
That's have I yet never not heard again.
Notice that the double negative results in a negative meaning not a positive
meaning. There are even some triple negatives in Bavarian.
These sentences mean because no one has any money, actually.
They're not full sentences. They're clauses, but here we go. And standard German
word for word it's because nobody money has and in Bavarian, right?
[Inaudible].
For what it's because nobody no money not has. Hmm. In English.
That's kind of like saying, because nobody ain't got no money,
which is possible in dialectal, English in middle high German,
double negatives were normal,
but variant seems to maintain more features of middle high German than standard
German does.
Now that we've looked at some of the differences between Bavarian and standard
German,
let's look at a couple more pairs of sentences and see what we find these
sentences mean. When I arrived, they hadn't eaten yet in standard German.
[Inaudible].
For word it's. When I arrived,
had they yet nothing eaten in.
As you all come up in [inaudible].
Word for word it's similar, but there's something different here,
which we'll come back to in a minute.
First in the word for when we see one of the pronunciation differences we
encountered earlier isle in standard German corresponds with oil in
Bavarian. Next we see the different subject pronouns, meaning I again,
or at least different forms of the same pronoun.
Then we see that the verb meaning arrive is conjugated differently in standard
German.
The verb is in the past tense while in Bavarian it's in the perfect tense.
So it has an auxiliary verb and this is it's past participle.
The past participle would be different than standard German and get Coleman.
Next. We can see that the auxiliary verb meaning had is pronounced differently.
We see the correspondence of awe and all,
and we see the loss of the unstressed E in Bavarian,
the word for yet takes a different form. Next in Bavarian,
we see the word Knicks, which is common among German dialects in general,
not only Bavarian,
it seems to be a contraction of Nicks and the gain and the final word.
We see the loss of unstressed eat another pair of sentences.
These sentences mean,
I think the teacher's opinion is nonsense in standard German.
[Inaudible].
For word it's.
I think the opinion of the teacher is nonsense and
in Bavarian.
Clap denied. No familiara is modern.
First notice that the verb meaning think is different.
Both verbs Behnken and Globen are used in both standard German and Bavarian.
So you could say either bank in Bavarian,
but globin is more common in Bavarian while banking is more common than standard
German note that Dinkin means think while globin means believe,
but they're often used interchangeably.
Next notice the different way of showing possession in the standard German
sentence.
This noun phrases in the genitive case with both the definite article and the
noun in the masculine singular genitive form.
Remember that Bavarian has no genitive.
So possession is shown with fun meaning of here it's foam,
because it's contracted with the date of case definite article dam,
which is for either masculine or neutral, by the way,
and notice that the noun doesn't have the genitive ending in Bavarian it's in
the date of case. Finally,
here we see that the Bavarian word for nonsense is different model.
It literally means a kind of scrambled pancake dish,
which looks pretty darn delicious.
If you ask me and the indefinite article here means that this is accountable
now,
as we've seen standard German and Bavarian differ from each other in several
different ways, but of course,
Bavarian dialects are not the only dialects that differ from standard German.
There are various dialects in all areas of Germany, Austria, Switzerland,
and South tea role. Of course, everyone learns standard German,
which unites the speakers of all those different dialects.
But of course they do throw some dialectal elements into their speech and speak
with regional accents that are influenced by those dialects.
The question of the day for speakers of non Bavarian varieties of German.
How well do you understand Bavarian speakers when they're using their dialects
and for speakers of Bavarian?
To what extent do you use Bavarian as opposed to standard German?
How does it differ depending on the situation,
please leave your comments after the video,
if you'd like learning German or Spanish, French, or English,
I recommend that you check out lingo.
What if I told you that you could take three months of classes with qualified
native speaking teachers and get a 100% refund,
you can do exactly that with the lingo to language sprint,
it's a challenge to you to take an online language class every day for three
months, if you complete the challenge, you'll get a 100% refund.
Now imagine that the powerful incentive of a 100% refund pushing you to
practice with a native speaking teacher every day,
imagine how much you could improve by taking lessons every day for three months
and how you would improve your time management and build the habit of
practicing. Every day recently taken some French classes with lingo.
Now I often read the news and French and things like that,
but I hadn't really spoken French much in a long time.
So I was feeling shy and nervous to speak it again.
But lingo to offers structured courses and structured lessons with fixed lesson
topics and downloadable study materials,
which has really made it comfortable and easy to jump back into speaking.
I can preview the vocabulary and the topic before the lesson.
So I feel confident when the lesson begins during this first few lessons,
I've had lots of speaking opportunities and it's made me feel motivated and
excited to continue.
I really think that you'll feel excited and motivated as well. Well,
the sprint starts on April 8th,
2020 and lasts until July 6th, 2020. There's the super sprint.
If you attend 30 classes a month for three months, you will get a 100% refund.
And there's the sprint. If you attend 15 classes a month for three months,
you'll get a 50% refund. There are classes for you,
no matter what your current level is,
all English and business English students will also have a chance to take a free
Cambridge assessment test online, sign up before March 24th.
There's a 49 Euro deposit.
But if you click the link in the description and use my promo code, join 97,
you'll get a ten-year-old discount on your deposit spaces for the language
sprint are limited. So sign up now so that you don't miss your chance.
Over 25,000 students have taken part in these lingo to challenges over the past
two years,
I recommend you check out their Instagram page and see why so many people love
lingo to special. Thanks goes out to the Lang focus channels,
Patrion supporters, especially these people whose names appear on the screen.
They are the top tier of Patrion supporters.
So many extra special thanks to them as always and to everyone.
Thank you for watching and have a nice day.